if you follow Marvel Entertainment on
Twitter or just generally lurk the
internet like I do you may have caught
this photo yesterday the photo told fans
to please stand by and tune in tomorrow
which is today for a special
announcement there was a lot of
speculation and theories concerning this
photo whether it was about the movie
whether it's about the comics but if you
look in the bottom right you can see
that it clearly says hashtag Marvel
Comics now that could be just a hashtag
used by Marvel Entertainment but today
at 12 o'clock we received the news that
it was indeed referring to the Marvel
comic universe today Marvel
Entertainment tweeted out and uploaded
to YouTube a video with Ryan pan agos
aka Marvel's agent and CB Sapolsky who
is Marvel's editor-in-chief to announce
exciting new comic releases coming out
in the summer H&M goes on the state that
Marvel is in a really great place right
now and the summer is getting
kick-started off in May with Avengers
number one with all the new releases
coming out in the summer Marvel said
they focused on four important tenants
with the new releases that is new series
new creative teams new beginnings and
new directions
agent n thing goes on the state that the
summer is just going to be bonkers and
then CBC Volsky replies by saying if
you're a comic fan it's not going to be
a better time to be a Marvel reader they
then go on to announce some of the new
releases such as new Captain America in
number one Black Panther number one life
of Captain Marvel number one and then
the huge announcement that Fantastic
Four will be returning with the original
members Reed Johnny bin and Su suppose
he stated that they had been waiting for
the right creative team for this book to
make its return in which he then
announced Dan Slott who did amazing
spider-man with Sarah pick Ellie this is
super exciting for everyone because Dan
has such great knowledge of the
Fantastic Four and will be respecting
the past stories but driving the new
ones forward with creative thinking and
new approaches we haven't seen before
and Sarah is so talented and good with
the acting in the comics such as body
language and facial expressions it's
gonna be super exciting to be able to
read the new Fantastic Four book in the
summer so that's it for the Marvel
update a lot of new exciting books
coming out in the summer what are you
most excited to get your hands on this
summer and read let me know which one
you'll read first and are most excited
about in the comments below be sure to
drop a like and subscribe to my channel
to stay up-to-date on Marvel Comics
thank you so much for watching
have a great day